welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and oh my stars and garters we need
to talk about Hank McCoy beast and how
good his VFX look for Kelsey grammar's
return as the mutant in the post-edit
scene of the marbles which everyone
online is now discovering now that the
movie is finding its way to a digital
release as without a doubt the most
important post-edit scene so far in
Marvel's Multiverse Saga the specific
Design Elements and word choices in the
scene cannot go ignored and sadly a lot
of people slept on this scene because it
was attached to a movie they felt they
didn't need to see you but I am telling
you now that in 2024 I've been going
back through each of the fox X-Men films
and our X-Men Snick Snick rewatch our
breakdown of x3 X-Men the Last Stand is
coming to the channel on Monday and this
is the movie that introduced Kelsey
gramar as Hank McCoy considering what
these movies do with the character it's
fascinating that this is the version of
Beast we are getting in the MCU his new
look what he is wearing what he says why
he's at the expansion at all all of this
is just telling us quite a bit about
Marvel Studios planed for the X-Men in
the upcoming titles so I figured we got
to go back and look at the scene now
that we can see everything in more
pristine detail and I'm going to break
down the VFX process of bringing this
CGI version of Beast to life why exactly
it looks so good and how it is both a
continuation of the fox X-Men films
while also its own thing and I
discovered a few new things in this post
credit scene that I don't know if they
wanted us to find okay when Kelsey
gramar played Hank McCoy in 2006's X-Men
the Last Stand the character's features
were created with makeup and latex
Prosthetics that took 3 hours to apply
with makeup around the eyes and lips and
various hair pieces for the button shops
along with gramer having to wear a
muscle suit covered with a hand punched
fur suit in a 2005 set visit attended by
CBR gramer said that he would have to
overemphasize his acting through his
eyes since so much of his face was
otherwise covered which is interesting
now to think about the way he played the
character now could play things a bit
more subtle and bring a slightly more
grounded performance to the role but in
2005 when gramar was asked about the
character's look in that film he said
that the designers wanted to make his
costume and older vintage X-Men suit
from Hank's time when he was a younger
member of Charles Xavier's crew and not
yet in a politic ICS but they wanted to
play up the joke that he no longer fits
into it like there's a gag in the 2006
film when McCoy resigns from being the
Secretary of mutant Affairs and returns
to being part of the X-Men but the suit
just doesn't fit it's just beast in
leather pants and a shirtless open vest
also in the 2006 film Beast does say
this catchphrase as they approach
Alcatraz all my stars and Carters this
was BEAST's longtime catchphrase in the
comics and in the X-Men animated series
in the '90s and reportedly it was that
Kevin F's insistence as he was a
producer on this film yeah one thing
we're learning in this rewatch series is
that from the first Fox X-Men film
onward Kevin feige had a role in pretty
much every Marvel film that got produced
during this decade because Marvel
entertainment would license this IP to
other film studios and fige was the guy
who would consult on how best to adapt
that comic book character for the big
screens so it's not like Kevin feige was
this Marvel wonderin from the start he
was alongside all these other filmmakers
experimenting with trial and error to
learn lessons on what to do and what not
to do with Marvel movies getting it
right in Iron Man came after a decade of
getting it wrong and a lot of other
movies but this history is important to
know because Kevin feig's backstory with
the way these characters were put on
screen informs how we are going to see
how he's putting them on screen now this
version of beast in the Marvel's post
credit scene is in a medical Bay in the
basement of the X mansion which in this
scene has similar blue XO we saw in the
fox films we never saw this room in
particular but in those Halls most of
the rooms had blue X doors except
cerebro which had a silver x door Monica
Rambo has gone through a rift in reality
opened by darbin using the two Quantum
bands she wakes up with a variant of her
mother Maria Rambo at her bedside but
Maria in this universe is spary and
you'll notice in this reality she wears
the quantum bands Beast enters this
scene and leaves this room from the side
of this glass in Partition but we never
see him go through the X door which
makes me wonder if this is a whole
medical Wing that goes a lot further
back this is different from the medical
Bay that we saw in the first X-Men film
from 2000 when Logan was being examined
by Gene gray or in X-Men the Last Stand
when the roles were reversed and it was
genan gy/ Phenix who was being examined
by Logan so it's like the same expansion
basement but but like bigger in a
different era of its history like they
want it to look familiar but also
establish some different architecture
and that also obviously applies to
Hank's appearance he's wearing a white
lab coat with the name badge and he
wears these blue and yellow pants that
I'm pretty sure were taken directly from
the very first issue of The Uncanny
axmen number one in 1963 by Stanley and
Jack Kirby before Beast was even blue
and furry they gave him the same pants
but the reason I'm so hung up on the ID
badge is in the fox X-Men films while
these facilities in the basement of the
expansion world is pretty legit and
high-tech the mutants working in those
rooms were never like large enough in
number to require any of them having to
wear an ID badge like there was just
like a handful of them like 10 of them
there wasn't really like any kind of
clerical admin organization where they
had to like scan their badges or show it
to security like they were the X-Men
there could only be as many of them that
could fit in the Blackbird the school
above them had 100 kids which now that
you think of it is also a very very
small school I'm just saying this is a
different version of Hank McCoy than any
of the Hank McCoy we saw in the fox Xmen
films and it's closer to the Hank McCoy
that that we saw in the '90s X-Men
animated series like he looks like
McDreamy or MC steamy if all they had
time to grab order with their white La
coats he's wearing nothing under the lab
code so there's just a lot going on at
this x- Manion basement it's bigger and
they require ID like I think we should
look at this as something like the
backer Foundation HQ in Multiverse of
Madness that was built on a set that was
designed to look like the British museum
in London this is like a whole operation
we are seeing an X-Men universe that is
either far into the future or just like
on a different timeline than what we saw
before and been The Last Stand after
resigning from the president's cabinet
by the end of that film Hank McCoy is
appointed to be the UN Ambassador it was
implied that he used to teach at the
school and fight alongside the X-Men but
he is now taken on a life as a
politician and Diplomat when Logan
passes by Hank McCoy and grammar's cameo
in Days of Future Past when the timeline
has been altered and restored Hank McCoy
is wearing a more professorial plaid
suit it's implied that he's like a
teacher now so this version of Hank
McCoy back in the white lab coat doesn't
seem to be working as a diplomat he's
now working for Charles Xavier tracking
multiversal anomalies he's a true
sciencetist stist like this is a nerd's
delight at this point no one has day
jobs they're just full-time X-Men now
the design of Beast here actually came
from artist Andy Park who shared some of
his concept art on his Instagram he's
the one who rendered these underbite
bangs the glasses and the ID badge I
also like how Andy designed him to not
have an exposed chest but rather you
know put his shirt on but it is untucked
this video is sponsored by Helix sleep
so is my life kind of I sleep like a
rock on my Helix mattress literally
every night and now you can get 20 % off
on a helix mattress plus two free
pillows if you're feeling overwhelmed by
the thought of finding a perfect
mattress I get it I've been there but
helix's sleep quiz makes it so easy you
just take the quiz and Helix finds the
perfect mattress for you I wanted a
medium burm mattress with lumbar support
that sleeps cool and I got matched with
the dusk Lux Helix mattress this year
Helix launched their newest and most
high-end collection yet the Helix Elite
mattress the Helix Elite collection
includes six different mattress models
that combine personal comfort with high
and luxury which means 2024 could be the
year you fall in love with your new
Helix Elite Helix delivers your mattress
right to your door with free shipping in
the US the mattress comes rolled up in a
box and it's super easy to set up
yourself Helix has a 100 night sleep
trial so you get more than 3 months to
make sure you love your mattress Helix
mattresses have a 10-year warranty Helix
even offers financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away I love
my Helix mattress and I think you would
too so if you're looking for a new bed
check out Helix sleep you can get the
link below or go to Helix sleep.com
rockstars to get 20% off your Helix
mattress plus two free pillows but
notice how Park conceived this Beast to
be a bit younger it's almost like we're
expected to see beast in this film not
as Kelsey's scammer age but like before
his life as a politician the effect
Outlet before and afters interview Tera
DeMarco who worked in the film and on
the VFX and said that this was a very
specific vision for Beast that came from
Marvel Studios to include a broader
forehead a more beast-like nose whatever
that means and the prating teeth
Demarcus said that the full CGI Beast
was a collaboration with petro ponti and
the team from ilm London and they
accomplished the best possible lip sync
by doing a comprehensive fact session at
otoy in downtown Los Angeles they
captured his dialogue in two ways in a
pop-up Medusa booth and also in an anema
capture volume with facial tracking
markers and a head mounted camera otoy
by the way is a company that uses octane
render which is one of the sharpest
applications for these kinds of effects
in the interview DeMarco said first they
recreated the actor's likeness matching
the otoy output once the actor likeness
was achieved they modified the base
model and Blended shapes from the videv
concept this allowed the model to be
grounded in the actor's proportions
proportion was key for the animation
phase as we wanted to map actor
performance to BEAST's features we then
really pushed Fidelity in the skin
texture always using the otoy reference
shoot as a starting point for skin for
the groom we recreated the hairstyle as
close as possible to the comics trying
to find the balance with realism and
what we saw from the iconic style of
Beast the final VFX challenge was
believing the lip sync on very complex
lines of dialogue delivered through
retreating teeth extensive shot work was
required for the final dialogue making
sure the characteristic actor mouth
shapes were not Lost in Translation as
we remapped the performance onto the
digital Beast yeah they put a lot of
work into this and it was very important
to see this Beast pronounce words like
alternate reality and all the scientific
multiversal mumbo jumbo that they had
Kelsey Grammar say in the scene it was
essential to see Beast mouth these words
and for it to look real yes they did use
a similar process that they used with
Mark R Josh Brolin and Tatiana masani
for She-Hulk but here they really wanted
those fangs to be poking against the
lips in a specific way and for us to not
question it or fall into The Uncanny
Valley for this moment so the fact that
they put all this effort into getting it
perfect I think is an indicator that
this isn't the only time we're going to
see Beast the X-Men Charles Xavier and
Wolverine that we meet in Deadpool 3 I
think have got to be joined by this
version of Beast now I did mention that
there were some new details I caught I
was referring to the pants legs from the
comics but I think there was also this
check out this part of the scene
confusion is but the first step on the
journey to
knowledge
I'll take it from here Charles asked for
an
update I'll come buy and check on you
later C did you catch anything there
there was definitely a slightly awkward
cut from the two shot of binary and
Beast to the profile shot of Monica
watch it
again I'll take it from here Charles
asked for an
update I'll come buy a check on you
later yeah we only hear in voiceover
Beast saying Charles asked for an update
and then we never see his face move were
saying anything else throughout the rest
of the scene we just cut to him in wide
as he's on his way out the door
awkwardly through the left side of the
frame that's the last we see of him and
yeah all 24 frames per second that we
see a beast have to be like rendered and
so every second literally counts with
beast but they didn't have to cut the
scene this way I think they cut it this
way so that if they had to remove the
mention of Charles Xavier they could or
they might have had other different
X-Men names that Kelsey gramar actually
said and they just ended up with just
Charles something was tinkered here but
either way mentioning Charles wanting an
update on this Multiverse I visitor is
very important because I spotted a
detail all the way back in the first
X-Men film when Patrick Stewart lectures
to his students this so I'd like your
definitions weak and strong anthropic
principles on my desk on Wednesday all
right I go into it more in the breakdown
but weak versus strong anthropic
principles refers to our perceptions of
reality in the possible existence of
other alternate universes beyond our
perception so all the way back in that
first movie that version of Professor X
was thinking about the Multiverse folks
and now here we are I believe the next
time we see these characters it's going
to be in a universe where the X-Men were
in their Prime something closer to the
X-Men animated series or exactly where
Lee and Kirby first introduced them back
in 1963 with vibrant costumes comic
accurate under bites and the trappings
that feige worked so hard to include in
those films from the 2000s and now we're
just going to see these nerds with
mutant abilities debating the existence
of the Multiverse so please watch our
breakdown of X-Men the Last Stand that's
coming Monday and watch our breakdowns
of the first two X-Men films and if you
haven't already please please please
subscribe to this channel give this a
like I'm Eric Boss thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
bye